well the thing that I would like to have  an answer to the most is to in a sense  no in human populations some of the  patterns of biological embedding and how  evolution fits together with biological  embedding in other words to really be  able to understand the evolutionary  signals and how the body understands you  know the experiences how they get down  in there how they select a spectrum of  genes to influence and so forth so I  want I don't only want to know that  there are experiences and they change  gene expression and that changes us but  I want to understand the rationale for  it the physiology of it the mechanisms  of it I want to see it all laid out in  ways that we can turn back and go okay  so this is the way in which human  experience plays with our biology and  vice versa